.
WE HAVE LEARNED THAT HE HAS
APPOINTED THREE ASSASSINATION
ATTEMPTS SINCE THE RUSSIAN
INVASION BEGAN.
THE LATEST FROM KIEV, UKRAINE.
SPEAK A LOT OF INFORMATION --
PARTICULARLY RELATED TO TWO
ASSASSINATION ATTEMPTS.
THIS INVOLVED MERCENARIES, WITH
THIS SHADOWING GROUP CALLED THE
WAGONER GROUP.
THEIR SUBCONTRACTS WOULD BE
WORKING WITH THE RUSSIAN
GOVERNMENT, DENYING THEM AND
USING SOME PADDING.
PREPLACED IN KIEV, ACTIVATED --
BUT THERE WERE QUESTIONS WHO
DON'T SUPPORT THE WAR, SO THEY
LEAKED INFORMATION TO UKRAINE
SECURITY SERVICES, AND THESE
PLOTS WERE FOR AGENDA.
THE OTHER INVOLVED A CHECHEN HIT
SQUAD THAT WERE PART OF THIS
BRIGADE, AND THAT'S THE ONLY
UNIT NAMED AFTER -- THEY WERE
INSERTED INTO THE COUNTRY WHEN
THE FIGHTING -- AT THE
AIRPORT -- ONCE AGAIN, THERE
WERE RUSSIAN TURNCOATS WHO
TIPPED OFF THE UKRAINIANS COME
APPARENTLY WITH DETAILED
INFORMATION, AND THE UKRAINIANS
WERE ABLE TO LOCATE THE
ASSASSINS AND KILL THEM RIGHT
THERE AT THE AIRPORT.
THAT INFORMATION CAME THROUGH
THE NATIONAL SECURITY TEAM HERE.
A REAL SPY STUFF GOING ON.
>> WE ARE SEEING THAT PLAY OUT
IN UKRAINE, BUT IN RUSSIA NOW,
WE'RE SAYING THIS TO SHUTDOWN.
FACEBOOK, ANOTHER SOCIAL MEDIA
COMPANY COMMAND MARTIAL LAW --
SEEING A NUMBER OF RUSSIANS
RIGHT.
CAN YOU COMMENT ABOUT THE
PROPAGANDA WAR THERE?
>> AS THEY SAY, THE FIRST
CASUALTY IN WAR IS THE TRUTH.
I'M SURE THERE'S A LOT OF
PROPAGANDA HERE, BAD INFORMATION
THAT COMES OUT WHEN YOU SEE THE
CASUALTY FIGURES.
YOU CAN'T TRUST ANY OF THEM.
YOU SAW THE CASUALTIES THEY CAME
UP WITH THE UKRAINIANS --
DRAMATICALLY DIFFERENT.
YOU GO TO FIND VIDEO THE
EVIDENCE TO FIND SOMETHING THAT
WOULD SUPPORT THESE DIFFERENT
STORIES, AND IT'S JUST NOT
THERE.
WHEN YOU ARE IN AN ENVIRONMENT
LIKE THIS, YOU HAVE TO -- HOPE
THAT YOU DON'T GET BAMBOOZLED.
>> TELLS ABOUT THIS WAGONER
GROUP.
I HAD MOST GOOD IDEA YOU COULD
SUBCONTRACT OUT A HIT, AT LEAST
NATIONALLY, AND THEN WIPE YOUR
HANDS LEAN.
DOES PUTIN THINK HE COULD PULL
THE TRIGGER ON SOMETHING LIKE
THIS?
>> A LOT OF IT GOES BACK TO
THAT -- KNOWN AS THE BAKER AND
RUSSIAN CIRCLES.
-- THE CHEF, I WOULD SAY.
PUTIN LIKED THE WAY HE COOKED,
SO HE GOT FOLDED INTO THE INNER
CIRCLE.
DOES A LOT OF ODD JOBS, AND HIS
TIMING -- ONE RIGHT DOWN TO THE
INTERNET RESEARCH ASSOCIATION.
HE'S TIED INTO THAT GROUP,
PROVIDING ALSO SO MUCH
INFORMATION, BECAUSE THEY ARE
SHADOWING -- THE WHOLE BACKBONE
OF THEIR ORGANIZATION.
>> FASCINATING.
THANK YOU.
>> WE ARE TALKING ABOUT THESE
ASSASSINATION ATTEMPTS ON
ZELENSKYY.
HAVE YOU HEARD ANYTHING ABOUT
THEM ON PUTIN?
EVEN HIS OWN PEOPLE ARE LEAKING
INFORMATION.
NOW, THEY ARE GETTING THEIR
SOCIAL MEDIA SHUTDOWN, THEY HAVE
STATEWIDE PROPAGANDA GOING ON
ABOUT HOW THEY ARE MILITARIZING.
HAVE YOU HEARD ANYTHING ABOUT
THAT?
>> IT IS VERY CLEAR THAT PUTIN
IS PARANOID.
YOU COULD HAVE A BOWLING MATCH
SET UP BETWEEN HIM AND HIS
CLOSEST ADVISORS, AND -- HE IS
FEARFUL OF COVID.
THEY KNOW IF THEY GET SWABBED --
COULD JUST KILL HIM.
ASSASSINATION PLOTS, I WOULD
IMAGINE THEY KEEP THAT SECRET.
>> I IMAGINE THEY DO.
[LAUGHTER]
>> THIS IS WHO YOU TALKED ABOUT.
HE'S BEEN TIGHT WITH PUTIN FOR A
LONG TIME.
HE IS APPEARING TO BE OVERSEEING
WITH SOME OF THESE.
32, PROBABLY MORE PLOTS, TO TRY
TO KILL HITLER, AND NONE
SUCCEEDED.
HE KILLED HIMSELF IN A BUNKER.
ZELENSKYY IS OBVIOUSLY UNDER
SOME OF YOUR DAILY PRESSURE.
WHAT IS THAT SHE'S CHANGING THE
WAY HE NAVIGATES THE END HE HAD
A LASER PIN ON HIM TO TRY TO
FIGURE OUT, STICK SOMETHING ON
HIM PHYSICALLY SO THEY COULD
FIND HIM?
>> THAT'S ADVANCED.
I DON'T KNOW A LOT ABOUT THAT,
BUT AS FAR AS THE PRESSURE THAT
ZELENSKYY IS UNDER AND WHAT HE'S
DOING -- KEEP IN MIND, THE
RUSSIAN LEADERS ARE PARANOID,
ONCE ANNEXED TO THE CLOSEST
ADVISORS.
ZELENSKYY IS DOING A PRESS
CONFERENCES, IS IN THE MIDDLE OF
ALL OF THIS.
PARTICULARLY IN THE WEST, HE WAS
NOT THAT POPULAR.
THIS IS A GUY WHO WAS AN ACTOR,
FELL INTO THIS JOB, AND EVEN HIS
POLITICAL PARTY IS NAMED AFTER
THE POLITICAL PARTY FROM THE TV
SERIES HE WAS IN.
A LOT OF PEOPLE THOUGHT HE WAS
NOT UP TO THE TASK.
HE'S RISEN TO THE OCCASION, ONLY
SO PEOPLE WHO DIDN'T LIKE HIM
ARE NOW BACKING HIM, BUT THERE
ARE SCENES OF THE BROADCASTED
ADDRESS HE JUST MADE.
HE WENT TO THE SQUARE IN THE
CZECH REPUBLIC, PACKED WITH
PEOPLE WHO ARE RALLYING BEHIND
ZELENSKYY.
IT IS REMARKABLE THE EXTENT TO
WHICH HE HAS RISEN TO THE
OCCASION.
>> I SHOULD HAVE DOUBLE THIS,
BUT I HAVE READ THAT RUSSIA
PASSED A NEW LAW IMPOSING PRISON
TERMS FOR SPREADING
MISINFORMATION ABOUT THE RUSSIAN
MILITARY, AND THE DEPRESSING
PART ABOUT THIS IS THAT THERE
ARE NO LAWMAKERS IN THEIR
PARLIAMENTARY CHAMBERS THAT
OPPOSE THE BILL.
I'M COMING FROM THE POINT OF
VIEW THAT THE KEY IS YOU HAVE TO
PERSUADE POWERFUL RUSSIANS --
THAT PUTIN IS NOT JUST A STRING
UKRAINE, BUT DESTROYING WORSHIP.
WHEN YOU SEE LAWMAKERS NOT
OPPOSING THIS BILL, THAT'S KIND
OF DEPRESSED.
>> SURE.
NOW -- WHEN YOU STOP TO TALK
ABOUT MISINFORMATION SPREADING.
THE DEFINITION OF FAKE NEWS, AS
POPULARLY INTERPRETED, IT'S
ANYTHING YOU DON'T WANT TO HEAR.
SOMETHING THE GOVERNMENT DOESN'T
LIKE, COULD BE PRISON TIME, AND
THEREFORE, HE WILL HAVE THIS
MEDIA -- I'VE BEEN IN THIS
COUNTRY FOR THE MEDIA IS
CONTROLLED AND USUALLY, THE
NEWSPAPERS ARE RIDICULOUS,
PRAISING WHOEVER IS IN POWER AT
THE TIME.
IT'S NOT JUST A MISTRUST OF THE
PEOPLE YOU GET -